[Musique]
la réalité c'est un thème central ce
soir mais on devrait plutôt dire votre
réalité car dans cette salle chacun
d'entre vous a une perception qui est
unique car son cerveau est unique en
tant que neuroscientifique je vais vous
donner quelques éléments pour vous aider
à comprendre comment votre cerveau
perçoit son environnement mais aussi
comment une personne autiste perçoit le
sien alors commençons par un exemple je
vais vous montrer une image et vous
devrez simplement déterminer ce qu'elle
représente
bon rien de difficile ici mais vous
n'avez peut-être pas perçu la même chose
que votre voisin étant donné qu'on peut
y voir deux animaux différents et en
fait des chercheurs ont montré que
lorsque on présentait cette image à des
enfants pendant les vacances de pâques
alors ils étaient plus susceptibles d'y
percevoir un lapin tandis qu'à la
toussaint ils allaient plutôt y voir un
canard donc ce petit exemple assez
simple nous montrent bien que dans les
cas où l'information sensorielle est
ambigu comme ici alors notre perception
va dépendre du contexte
on va continuer avec un autre exemple
normalement nous devrions tous être
d'accord pour dire que ces deux cases a
et b ont la même tente de grille et
pourtant quand on les replace dans le
contexte d'un échiquier
alors ces deux casse semble très
différentes je vous laisse revoir
et même en vous contant
rangez pas mal essayé ça devient
impossible de retrouver l'ancien percept
où les deux cases étaient identiques
en fait vu que vous savez que l'ombre du
cylindre de vrais noircir la casse b
alors votre cerveau interprète que cette
case était blanche ce que vous avez
perçu votre perfect est donc en fait à
mi chemin entre les informations reçues
est ce que votre cerveau projette ce à
quoi il s'attend en neurosciences ses
prédictions ses attentes s'appelle des a
priori et nous sommes constamment en
train d'apprendre et d'ajuster nos a
priori pour se former une représentation
globale du monde qui nous emploient nous
avons donc en tête une sorte de modèle
interne qui nous aide à comprendre notre
environnement mais qui va le sien peut
déformer nos perceptions pour la faire
ressembler à ce que nous connaissons
déjà pour décrire ce phénomène on parle
de cerveau probabiliste ou pro à qui on
dit pro actif car votre cerveau n'est
pas un organe qui recevrait passivement
flux d'informations au contraire il va
activement générer des prédictions pour
essayer d'interpréter son environnement
et d'anticiper par exemple là pendant
que je vous parle votre cerveau est en
train d'essayer de prédire
chaque mot que je vais prononcer il fait
ça en fonction de ce qu'il a appris dans
le passé donc finalement on pourrait
dire que nous sommes toujours légèrement
dans le futur et dans le passé à la fois
mais rarement vraiment dans le présent
et ses prédictions peuvent être parfois
précise par exemple vous n'aurez pas de
difficultés pour terminer la phrase je
pense donc je suis merci mais vous
auriez été sans doute plutôt étonné que
je les termine par je pense donc je skie
oui il arrive que ces prédictions soit
fausse ce qui va vous surprendre mais
parfois vous faire sourire ou contraire
plutôt vous angoissez en neurosciences
on parle d'erreur de prédiction pour
décrire ces décalages entre
l'information reçue est ce que votre
cerveau projette ce à quoi il s'attend
et grâce à ces erreurs de prédiction
vous allez pouvoir mettre à jour votre
modèle interne pour être adapté au mieux
à son environnement à votre
environnement et il faut parfois un peu
de temps pour pouvoir mettre à jour ses
a priori par exemple je sais pas si ça
vous est déjà arrivé d'être surpris par
votre propre reflet dans le miroir
après avoir changé de coupe de cheveux
simplement parce que vous ne vous êtes
pas encore habitués vous n'avez pas
encore ni à jour votre modèle interne
dans l'ensemble les a priori ses
prédictions pour nous aider à comprendre
notre environnement
mais si on a des a priori trop précis ça
peut être problématique car si vous avez
des a priori extrêmement précis alors
ceux ci seront toujours fortement en
décalage par rapport à l'information
reçue dans ce cas le moindre changement
le moindre imprévu susciterait une forte
erreur de prédiction une forte
ra une forte pendant un port et fête
surprise
et puisque nous vivons dans un monde qui
en perpétuel changement
alors nous serions en quelque sorte
bombardé d'erreur de prédiction ce qui
serait tout à fait envahissant et
stressant un autre point problématique
sur le fait d'avoir des a priori très
précis c'est que ça peut nuire à la
catégorisation prendre l'exemple d'un
sourire si vous avez un a priori plutôt
vague de ce qu'un souhait c'est à dire
juste sa forme globale alors vous aurez
peu difficultés pour faire correspondre
l'information reçue avec votre a priori
vous pouvez donc le catégoriser comme un
sourire et donc l'interpréter alors que
dans le cas contraire vous auriez un a
priori extrêmement précis alors le
décalage par rapport à l'information
sensorielle sera plus grand ce sera donc
plus difficile de catégoriser et donc
plus généralement de pouvoir catégoriser
les expressions faciales
dans ce cas la compréhension des
interactions sociales serait un peu
altérée
et ce qui est particulièrement
intéressant c'est qu'il ya justement un
trouble dans lequel les personnes ont
des difficultés pour comprendre les
interactions sociales et pour gérer les
imprévus
il s'agit des troubles du spectre de
l'autisme qui sont officiellement
caractérisée par deux types de symptômes
les premiers ce sont des difficultés
pour comprendre les interactions
sociales
donc ça va être par exemple comprendre
les expressions du visage ou de second
degré et sur ce point das ce sont
surtout les enfants autistes qui meurent
par tendance à tout interpréter au
premier degré donc on comprendra bien
qu'il puisse être plus qu'étonné quand
on parle de jeter un coup d'oeil ou de
donner sa langue au chat
le second type de symptômes ça va être
des comportements répétitifs donc par
exemple ça peut être des mouvements de
balancement qui vont être invariablement
répétées et des intérêts restreints
en fait c'est simplement une passion
dans laquelle ils sont souvent
incollables comme les tran en tant que
neuroscientifique nous avons cherché à
savoir si ces symptômes de l'autisme
pourrait être expliquée par une
perception atypique dans le cadre du
cerveau proactif nous avons donc
développé des expériences afin de
comprendre comment les personnes
autistes se construisent des a priori et
comment elles émettent à ce jour nos
expériences ont montré que les personnes
autistes peuvent parfois se construire
des a priori très précis donc
difficilement généralisable il ya un
exemple que je donne souvent parce que
je trouve assez parlant c'est un adultes
autistes qui m'a expliqué que quand on
évoque un sourire et bien lui il a en
tête la liste de tous les sourires vu
presque exclusivement ceux de sa femme
d'ailleurs un peu à la manière de google
images
pour caricaturer et donc il fait ça
plutôt qu'avoir en tête juste l'image
moyenne un sourire donc vous comprendrez
bien que ce sera plus difficile pour lui
de pouvoir interpréter automatiquement
et rapidement les expressions du visage
nos expériences aussi montré que les
personnes autistes ont besoin d'un peu
plus de temps pour pouvoir
tra jourdain après lui pour pouvoir les
réajuster et c'est cohérent avec le fait
que dans l'autisme le moindre changement
par exemple quelques minutes de retard
sur un train et en france on est servi
avec ça et bien juste ça ça peut être un
réel bouleversement pour eux et c'est
aussi la nature même des sensations des
sensations en elle-même qui le
ressentent souvent imprévus imaginez si
chaque sensation
chaque son chaque mouvement chaque odeur
était aussi surprenant que le son que
vous venez d'entendre le ressenti aurait
été bien sûr très différent si vous vous
attendiez à entendre ce son que je vais
rejouer maintenant en fait en quelque
sorte les personnes qui se
retrouveraient très souvent bombardé
d'erreur de prédiction à cause de toutes
ces sensations imprévus qui les mènerait
à des sortes de sensations
d'envahissement sensoriel à ce propos un
auteur autiste qui s'appelle daniel
thanet parler de son quotidien en
expliquant souvent le bruit était plus
impromptue qu'il n'était fort c'était
surtout parce que je ne m'y attendais
pas qu'il m'affectait
étape suivante de nos recherches a
consisté à comprendre sur quoi repose
l'apprentissage atypique de ces a priori
dans l'autisme
nous avons donc effectué une expérience
en irm fonctionnelle qui est une méthode
permettant d'obtenir une cartographie
des régions cérébrales activées pendant
une tâche
en utilisant cette méthode nous avons pu
montrer que dans l'autisme des a priori
modulerait des réseaux cérébraux
différents ce qui serait à l'origine de
cette perception un typique avec tous
ces résultats
l'autisme apparaît donc comme une
différence de perception sous tendu par
une différence de fonctionnement
cérébral il me paraît donc important de
souligner que l'autisme est bien un
trouble du développement cérébral
aboutissant à cette perception atypique
et une donc une personne naît autiste
elle ne le devient pas et sûrement pas à
cause de l' influence de la mer comme on
a pu parfois malheureusement le lire et
l'autisme est un sujet majeur étant
donné que une personne sur cent est
autiste qui représente 650 mille
personnes en france donc statistiquement
il est très probable que certains
d'entre vous ce soir soit autiste ou que
vous connaissiez les personnes autistes
et ce peut-être même sans le savoir sans
le savoir parce qu'il existe des formes
plus ou moins visibles d'autisme étant
donné qu'il s'agit d'un spectre d'un
continuum
quand on parle d' autisme vous pensez
peut-être au film rain man ou un enfant
solitaire qui ne parlerait pas mais il
existe aussi des formes bien moins
discernable du moins vu l'extérieur par
exemple le syndrome d'asperger heures
est une forme d'autisme sans déficience
intellectuelle et avec un langage tout à
fait développer julie d'achat notamment
caractérisée de différence invisible car
de l'extérieur on peut ne pas se rendre
compte que la personne est autiste se
dire éventuellement qu'elle est un peu
atypique ou réservés
mais de l'intérieur
c'est souvent une lutte intense pour
garder la face dans notre monde ici un
prédictive et où la moindre interaction
sociale peut s'avérer être une réelle
épreuve pour eux en plus de ces
symptômes
certaines personnes autistes présente
des capacités particulièrement
exceptionnelle c'est le cas de l'auteur
daniel thanet qui a été capable de
mémoriser les 22 1514 premières
décimales du chiffre pis donc ici j'en
ai mis que 2000
comme je vous laisse imaginer plus de
dix fois ça n'est pour lui quand il
observe ces chiffres il voit plutôt ça
un paysage de couleur à travers lequel
il navigue et qu'il peut facilement
mémoriser un autre exemple c'est
stéphane wiltshire un artiste autiste
qui a été capable de redessiner
notamment la ville de new york à la
perfection
après l'avoir seulement survolé en
hélicoptère
ces deux exemples sont assez médiatisé
donc peut-être que certains d'entre vous
les connaissez déjà mais il faut quand
même souligner que toutes les personnes
autistes n'ont pas forcément une sorte
de don ultra spectaculaire et les gens
s'attendent souvent à ce qu'il en est un
par exemple une femme m'a raconté ce qui
s'est passé quand elle a appris qu'elle
avait un syndrome d'asperger heures à
l'âge de 30 ans et qu'elle a décidé
d'annoncer à une de ses amies
donc l étonnant le salon et elle lui a
dit qu'elle avait une forme d'autisme
à ce moment-là son habit s'est absenté
quelques instants
puis quand elle est revenue elle avait
une boîte de cure-dents dans les mains
à ce moment là elle a renversé par terre
en lui disant alors il y en a combien
d'ailleurs à la question quel est ton
super pouvoirs certaines personnes
autistes répondent que c'est l'autisme
leurs super pouvoirs
car ça leur offre perception du monde
bien singulière et puis il faut aussi
garder à l'esprit que les personnes
autistes sont considérés comme
différente
simplement parce qu'elles sont la
minorité elles sont les 1%
donc des personnes autistes ont eu
l'idée de présenter le syndrome
neurotypiques pour nous définir nous qui
ne sommes pas autiste qui permet de
changer un peu de perspective donc
il s'agit d'un trouble incurable qui
touche 99% de la population est pourtant
pas de recherches sur le sujet et qui
est caractérisée par un besoin excessif
de relations sociales par l'utilisation
fréquente du mensonge par une obsession
pour la conformité tous et même par un
désintérêt total pour les trains en tant
que chercheur nous nous focalisons
souvent sur les symptômes sur les
difficultés que les personnes autistes
rend compte parce qu'on espère que nos
recherches pourront contribuer à trouver
comment rendre les situations
quotidiennes - épouvante pour eux mais
toutes les heures de discussions passées
avec des adultes autistes ou aussi
montré énormément d'aspects positifs et
à quel point nous pouvons apprendre
d'eux ce soir j'ai souvent parlé de
cerveau mais ce sont avant tout bien sûr
des personnes des individus avec
lesquels je travaille et qui mérite
qu'on accepte pleinement leur
singularité
la sensibilisation à l'autisme me semble
donc primordial pour que l'on considère
l'autisme comme une différence et non
une déficience les personnes autistes
ont évidemment des qualités humaines et
professionnelles mais beaucoup d'adultes
n'arrive toujours pas à avoir accès au
monde du travail viennent parfois
vraiment surdiplômés et beaucoup de
jeunes aussi ont encore du mal à avoir
accès à l'éducation
l'image encore très stigmatisante de
l'autisme fait que certaines personnes
ayant reçu leur diagnostic
à l'âge adulte n'ont toujours pas osé le
dire à leurs parents de peur que ça ne
nuise trop alors en à leur image ou
autre tout cela va donc renforcer leur
sensation d'isolement est sans doute lié
au fait que près de 70% des adultes
autistes déclarent des dépressions alors
par des efforts d'adaptation et
tolérance
nous pourrions aussi sans doute
contribué à diminuer le handicap
ressentie par ces personnes plus
globalement je pense qu'il nous
appartient on accepter une certaine
forme de neuro diversité l'idée que
différents modes de fonctionnement
peuvent coexister il s'enrichir
mutuellement
nous pourrions prendre cette diversité
comme une opportunité pour envisager de
nouvelles manières d'appréhender le
monde
et puis nous avons vu que notre cerveau
est capable de mettre à jour ses a
priori
alors mettons cela à l'oeuvre pour
changer de regard sur l'autisme
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]